the coronavirus pandemic and the rush to
vaccinate the people who are most at
risk in hospitals
and long-term care facilities the cdc
says more than 11 million doses of the
vaccine have been shipped in the u.s
but get this only about 2 million people
have actually been vaccinated so far
that's far
fewer than the trump administration
intended by the end of the year
you know hospitals are treating more
than 121 thousand covid patients this
morning and that is a new record
california is one of the states where
the virus is out of control and later
today
strict lockdown orders are expected to
be extended
in that state carter evans is in
pasadena california near los angeles
carter good morning
good morning huntington hospital behind
me says they've treated nearly
1500 covet patients here since the start
of the pandemic
and patient numbers are only expected to
rise after the holiday season
in fact california governor gavin newsom
says patient numbers
and hospitalizations could double within
the next month
california's battered hospitals are
bracing for another coronavirus surge
after the holidays in hard hit los
angeles county icus
are completely full and about 600 people
test
positive every hour i think we're now in
a viral tsunami
dr robert kim farley is a ucla
epidemiologist
the people who we're seeing in the
hospital now is that still the
thanksgiving surge
yes that's the reality of it i think
that we're in for still
um a big viral wildfire we have this
light
at the end of the tunnel the vaccine
that's coming but what's happening is
that this tunnel is looking
uglier and uglier every day and demand
for that vaccine is evident across the
country
hundreds of seniors lined up for hours
to get vaccinated at a florida community
center on monday
and in new york the owner of a network
of urgent care clinics was
ordered to return 2 300 doses of the
moderna vaccine
after allegations that it fraudulently
gave the vaccine to people who weren't
supposed to get it
in a statement the parcare clinic said
it's cooperated with authorities and has
provided information about its
compliance with the department of health
procedures
if you violate the law on these
vaccinations we will find out and you
will be
prosecuted 48 states are now sending the
first doses of the vaccine to some
long-term care facilities including the
life care center of kirkland
the first nursing home in the country to
experience a covet outbreak
in late february of this year greg and
laura roberts are nurses at river valley
care center in northern california
they say they were hesitant to take the
vaccine until the virus killed their 44
year old daughter
charity she had the respiratory arrest
then she had a heart attack her kidneys
shut down
and her liver failed all at the same
time
i'll be honest i was on the fence about
the vaccines i'll be first in line
everybody can stand to watch
to give you a sense of how dire the
situation is here in southern california
at huntington hospital they recently
released a document
preparing patients for the possibility
that they may have to ration
care if the situation continues to
deteriorate
if that happens a panel would then
decide
who gets treatment and who doesn't
adriana rationing care in the united
states carter thank you